After concatenation,
it's now time for minification to
shrink the file size of our JavaScript.
The most popular minifier today
is uglifyJS which does some heavy but
safe optimizations to squeeze every
last bit out of your raw source code.
And you might have guessed it, plug-in
and include it into the gulp-file.
Now this is where our scripts and
scripts-disk tasks are starting
to become slightly different.
As JavaScript minification is
a very time-intensive stop.
Therefore, it makes no sense to do
this while live-editing your code.
Add the missing pipe to the scripts-dist
task right after the concat pipe and
call it pipe uglify.
Yes, that's all you need and calling
this task now will produce nicely
concatenated and minified JavaScript.